je vous trouve actuellement à tilloy lez
marchiennes dans le nord cette commune
qui a défrayé la chronique l'an dernier
c'est ici qui a été élu pour la toute
première fois en france une mère
transgenres elle s'appelle mariko et
elle a accepté de nous recevoir
suivez-moi
maiko bonjour merci de nous recevoir
j'avais une première question en
préambule de nombreuses femmes féminiser
les noms fonction du coût est ce que je
dois vous appeler madame le maire ou
madame la maire mouassa pas d'importance
je pense que ce qui est plus important
c'est la fonction est ce que vous vous
attendiez à devenir un symbole même un
symbole malgré vous je m'attendais juste
un petit buzz locale c'est clair que ça
fait pas mal de buzz ma grande surprise
on a récupéré une commune qui était il
n'y avait plus beaucoup d'argent en
caisse donc il a fallu aussi remettre en
place toute la partie administration et
après on a lancé les projets de la fibre
optique qui était une attente importante
dans le village la rénovation de
l'ancienne mairie qui va devenir une
salle communale pour accueillir les
associations et toutes les activités
périscolaires vous êtes ingénieur mais
femme est ce que vous avez dû prouver
vos compétences vis-à-vis de niveau de
vos administrés et même avant votre
élection alors au tout début il a
d'abord fallu que je rassure comme chez
des personnes transgenres disais qu'est
ce qui va se passer plus en plus forte
du compte que deux voix là j'étais une
personne comme les autres d'après la
difficulté c'est plus quand on est femme
forcément connais rien à la technique
gens qui disent mais je peux pas vous
expliquer vous comprendrez par magie
ainsi je m'explique vous pouvez
m'expliquer je vais comprendre n'y a pas
de souci donc on a toujours cette
condescendance de certaines personnes
par rapport au fait d'être femme
et quelle est la perception selon vous
du débat sur le genre en france sur
cette question au niveau national
malheureusement c'est un des réflexions
qui aurait dû rester du niveau du
sociétal de l'étude sociologique et
c'est devenu un sujet politique alors le
genre ya eu des études sur le genre
lancée par les mouvements féministes
dans les années 70 qui étaient des
réflexions sur la construction sociale
du genre à ce que simone de beauvoir
disait on n'est pas femme on le devient
donc c'est une problématique plus tôt de
construction culturelle et sociale il
était resté un petit peu dans la sphère
du féminisme avec la visibilité des
personnes transgenres ce débat là est
revenu mais il a été un petit peu
galvaudé perverti et c'est devenu un
fantasme d'extrême droite qui voit chez
pearson tranchant où tout ce qui tourne
autour du jean comme une attaque entre
la sexualité la famille traditionnelle
et c'est ce qu'il faut faire parce qu'il
n'ya pas de turiddu gens ça n'existe pas
il ya eu des études sur le genre n'ya
pas théorie du genre donc c'est devenu
très politique c'est devenu un chiffon
rouge entre l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche qui au final desservent
les personnes lgbt puisqu'aujourd'hui on
se retrouverait d'une arène médiatique
qui nous dessert plutôt qu'elle ne sert
qu est ce que vous pensez par exemple de
la proposition de jean luc mélenchon de
changer la constitution pour y inclure
quelque chose sur la liberté des gens
oui je pense que c'est très démagogique
parce que c'est absolument pas besoin de
changer la constitution pour faire ça
c'est juste une problématique de code
civil donc il suffit de rajouter trois
lignes dans le code civil et pis c'est
bon donc là on est on là on est
clairement dans la démagogie c'est clair
aujourd'hui il ya des familles
monoparentales mais le rôle du beau
parent on a des problématiques sur
l'adoption l'accouchement sous x
filiation le problème de filiation pma
gp à ckoi parents biologiques
aujourd'hui le code civil est ancien et
les rites et d'une culture latine et
pinard et puis surtout napoléon donc
c'est ça nécessite une remise en
question il y avait une vision très
patriarcales des choses aujourd'hui ça
ça a changé faut pas être dans le déni
faut légiférer intelligemment sur ces
sujets là plutôt que laisser les
extrémismes sans parler de ces sujets
justement je vous ai entendu critiquer
par ailleurs le mouvement hawk
disons que ça faisait beaucoup de dégâts
parce que c'était pas assez qu'on prie
qu'est ce que vous vouliez dire ce que
vous pouvez développer un mouvement rock
à l'origine sépare d'un idéal
d'ouverture des consciences du respect
tout c'est très bien mais comme souvent
les idéaux sont perverties deviennent
des idéologies voir après des sectes et
là c'est effectivement ce qu'on assiste
avec le mouvement mot qui est un peu été
dénaturé devenu sectaire et qui
aujourd'hui ne correspond pas du tout à
la vision universaliste de la république
française et des oppresseurs des
oppressés manichéen c'est simpliste de
finale ça n'amène pas la compréhension
ça n'amène pas la tolérance ça n'amène
que le rejet et des postures de
agressive à vous êtes candidate à
l'élection présidentielle vous êtes en
train de réunir vos 500 signatures
quelle candidate serez vous à ce que
vous serez un porte étendard ou alors
qu'est ce que vous portez un projet plus
large c'est pas une candidature de
témoignage ni étendard je suis pas là
pour défendre un lobby une association
un mouvement politique on peut faire des
choses simples pour améliorer la
situation sans vouloir casser le système
sans en mettre en place des 6ème
république ou révolutionner les choses
je pense avec beaucoup de bienveillance
et d' écoute on peut améliorer les
choses assez facilement donc là c'est
plutôt une candidature citoyenne
hors parti parce qu'aujourd'hui les gens
n'ont plus confiance dans les partis et
donc il faut se réunir sont nos valeurs
et arrêter de se diviser
entre gauche droite sinon l'offre
politique va continuer à s'appauvrir et
on aura un non choix et annonce soit les
gens apprennent à s'exprimer dans
l'abstention dans l'extrémisme ou dans
les révoltes 2